I ended the previous lesson with a
question I asked you if the force of
friction comes into play only when the
two things are in relative motion let's
discuss this in detail let's say you
want to move the stationery sofa in your
living room and the sofa is really heavy
what happens when you give it an initial
push yes you're right nothing happens
the sofa doesn't move even though you're
applying a lot of force why do you think
the sofa doesn't move well the answer is
static friction the force that you apply
is balanced by a frictional force by the
floor and this force is applied in the
direction opposite to your push this
force is nothing but static friction the
concept of static friction is really
amazing why do I say that the reason why
I say that is because it is a
self-adjusting force as you increase
your force of push the force of static
friction increases - and the forces are
still balanced now I know what you must
be thinking after a few seconds the sofa
begins to move right what happens to the
static force then let's discuss this
with the help of a simple graph we
assume that the force you apply is a
horizontal force represented by the x
axis and the frictional force applied by
the flow is represented by the y axis
now as you increase the horizontal force
applied the frictional force is also
increasing accordingly to keep the sofa
at rest this continues till a point
where the sofa just starts moving and
that's where the static friction ends
and the sliding friction begins the
sliding friction is more or less
constant if you notice this part of the
graph is static friction it's when the
sofa is not moving in spite of the force
you're applying and this part of the
graph is sliding or kinetic friction
when the sofa begins to move the point
around which the sofa just begins the
movement is called the breakaway point
is there anything else you notice in the
graph why is this line at a lower level
than the maximum static frictional force
the reason is simple if you've ever
pushed a sofa or some heavy object on
the floor you would have realized that
pushing it is a little easier when it's
in motion yes it's because the sliding
friction is lesser than the static
friction that's offered by the floor
that was the concept of static friction
for you so we've seen three kinds of
friction so far static friction sliding
friction and rolling friction can you
place them in the increasing order of
force being applied by each yes static
friction is more than the sliding
friction which will be more than the
rolling friction in all the examples
we've seen so far we've only considered
friction between solid parts ball on a
flow box on a table or rollerskates on
the ground in all cases both the objects
were solid this friction come into play
only when solid parts are involved is
there any other kind of friction we
haven't seen yet do watch our next video
didn't know more
[Music]